[Aplausos]
[Música]
boa noite meu nome é luiz mulher sou
piloto do zero não comercial não
profissional e vou tentar num crime um
pouco tempo explicar os mais ou menos do
que 100 pilotos zelo ea visão z nas suas
várias matérias estranhas voada sempre
na terra e no céu de 2015
eu nunca vou provavelmente nós tem
perfeitamente idéia do que vou dizer que
voar é uma coisa que é privilégio das
nossas gerações
quase ninguém antes ninguém antes nossas
a nossa do nosso tempo teve o privilégio
de voar e portanto tem uma coisa que eu
acho que não devemos nunca utilizar
sempre utilizar a experiência única do
vovô uma coisa fantástica que eu não
posso escrever palavras tu falar de voar
em 2012
não estou a falar de um voo comercial
entre ambos do ponto a ao ponto b num
preço mais um metro do que outra coisa
e portanto se voar é uma coisa
extraordinária pintarem demais
fantástico
somos donos dos nossos e acima de tudo
que aconteceu mundo numa versão 3d é
imaginável e ninguém que não tenha feito
história não tem transmissão na visão
nós por contacto com a missão mas temos
uma coisa que é muito sérios de
exposições eo público num momento muito
facilmente e com muito entusiasmo é esta
sem piloto no grid mais complicado que é
nomeadamente o vovô longo tarefas sem
conseguir bater conduzir
falar ao telemóvel ler o jornal e vi a
mensagem e divulgar o gps desde
qualificações necessárias para ser
piloto que mais vezes faz quando está é
voar
tem que estar atento a essas coisas
todas filipe silva tem que saber onde é
que outras pessoas estão ea e outras
tarefas
ainda temos muita coisa que os vícios e
infrações têm de estar perfeitamente
conscientes dos riscos que nossa
habilidade reta é temos uma formação
adequada isso deve estar sempre atento
sempre consciente daquilo que a nossa
virada potter para isso também a
infrações
temos que estar atentos às licenças e
documentos caducados licença aeronaves
essas métricas temos ter conhecimento
dos desvios ao ano
temos áreas que não podemos entrar temos
atitude que temos não seremos regras
guaru nós temos nos faltou mostrar que
eles estão lá sempre prudentemente
informações que têm um conjunto não
perder de coisas que temos que ter
cuidado
só para dar uma idéia do piloto
comercial do z grande
temos aqui um piloto militar a missão
tem que fazer mas atrás dela tem uma
estrutura pessoal do terra
temos aqui o que a equipe também tentei
essa equipe toda que suporta o seu vôo e
temos aqui chamado adote uma vantagem
que não se sentir à vontade
isso é uma regra dor na versão do
browser
nós queremos dizer que mais vale um
piloto no chão com vontade de falar do
piloto à vontade
acham que o fórum formas voluptuosas com
dinheiro que fazem cac 40 avançou fazer
várias escolhas do nosso prefeito
avançou sozinho durante a transição
tranqüila o nosso forte liquidez tanto
por causa de um bom estilo saque o
piloto diz maravilhas não vou ter mais o
controle após entregar o estudo
meu nome é josé rocha é esse o controle
do tráfego aéreo desde 1985 tem 51 anos
e estoca essencialmente ajudar e
proteger é um dos marinheiros e os
pilotos brasileiros entre outros
objetivos como controle de tráfego aéreo
é são manter um fluxo espírito e seguro
os aviões evitar que os cuidam clara
evitar também que os entrem em áreas não
deve entrar disponíveis para isso são
agora com vocês podem ver os radares é
uma das ferramentas disponíveis onde
vizinhos e eu não consegui ter uma
panorama daquilo que eu posso fazer é um
painel comunicações para além de um
painel em tecnologia da informação para
ajudar os pilotos e dependendo onde eu
esteja a prestar o serviço é formar e
terminal e prestam serviço encontrou
tráfego intenso irmã tia esquerda forma
uma é fora fora dessas áreas é eu dou
informações aos alunos de lazer para se
evitarem aquela avião tem nada em são
paulo em um avião e assim evitam vendas
tanto estas ferramentas disponíveis que
eu tenho é para fazer um bom trabalho
isto não é assim tão simples é o nosso
passeio é portugal para além das áreas
terminais lisboa faro e do porto é tem o
transar isso não poderia deixar de ser
os militares tal como o varela é muito
real
cintra é montijo beija
todas essas áreas fazem com que uma vez
mais vamos centrar-nos pilotos do lazer
ou seja os vôos não comerciais aqui os
vôos que nom vez mais baixo é um piloto
queira ir por exemplo do lagos até lá em
cima até bragança não possa fazer a
linha reta apesar desse passeio a ver é
não podem fazê-lo em espaço aéreo é em
linha reta
vai nos passar então constituído não só
por estas áreas
como também é por outras áreas militares
além daquelas existem umas áreas que é
pra entender estarem ativas é
permanentemente existe hora de outras
áreas que estão ativas de quando em vez
temos as áreas de paraquedismo temos
áreas drones do planador temos outras
áreas como as áreas quando é dos
incêndios combatem incêndios e outros do
trabalho aéreo também as notas
essas áreas não sei que um pouco e segue
a costurar os pois vai ficar bonito
outra vez aos passos dessa coisa toda é
essas áreas têm avisos prévios para aqui
para que o escâner possa planear a em
vez de fazer um vôo direto até bragança
possa fazer os vizinhos e tal e consiga
atingir bragança mexendo dentro do
planejamento também estas áreas
militares não vida própria natureza da
área militar não podem ser programadas
com dois ou três dias antes para quem
não tem esses avisos o que acontece
acontece que é temos que de qualquer
maneira como controladora é arranjar
ferramentas para que é eu informo que
essas áreas estão ativas
isso leva a que o tem uma gestão do
espaço aéreo de frente ou seja eu apesar
de ter planeado e aproveitando você e eu
posso que dita as áreas muitas estarem
ativas ter passado por d
isto é surgiu de um lugar a uma
necessidade lugar uma cidade
uma cidadã é uma ideia foi um carro
competitivo que é um portal de
informação
bom o carro quando o pt é um portal sem
fins lucrativos que ajuda os pilotos e
depois vou para o piloto o planeamento
tocava com pt ficou muito mais como
tocava com e fica muito mais planejavam
mais fácil mas respeitar nossa já temos
tudo no mesmo sítio e quanto antes de
voltar a ver os amigos num site em um
dia no outro ser obra estava
profissionais ou não no outro é que
conseguimos integrar tudo num único site
em que nós conseguimos ter informação
toda atualizada e disponibilizada a
todos
é deste modo o planeamento é muito mais
facilitado para preocupar o piloto é
temos também uma área de tecnologia que
é atualizada semanalmente tomás colega
carlos martins que todos especialmente a
área fim de semana normais mas que
também temos a ferramenta as palavras de
hidrantes e temos também o piloto foi um
dos fundadores do site de notícias
internacionais e nacionais
todo nosso portal notícias controladora
é ouro sobre azul
temos 11 um portal que dá toda a
informação seja ela qual for
para o piloto z por aquilo que não tem
uma equipa atrás que possa
ganhar vou escrever sobre azul ou seja
eu consegue não só com o piloto do zero
mas também é para o é para os vouchers
de combater incêndios de fotografia
aérea enfim é é o carro consegue ser
abrangente é dar informação para todas é
a comunidade aeronáutica
essa é uma informação atualizada todos
dizem um trechinho que esta manhã
estamos cá atualizar o nosso o nosso
carro com informação sobre as áreas tais
áreas militares vão estar activos para
esse dia para lá em todas as outras que
já estão programadas e também pode ser
consultado um computador num smartphone
enfim onde haja internet mesmo até no
voo
eu não vou deixar que vou mal tudo em
quito na internet com cimar fonte
consegue ter a atualização das áreas
estão ativas
isso leva a que eu como controlou têm
uma menor intervenção se eu sabendo não
tem que evitar tudo isso onde de a prevê
esse e ver e eu apenas tem sido o vôo em
utilizar o vôo não tem que agendar é
sempre chamou a atenção para ver evitar
isto ou aquilo vai também é viabilizar a
poupança de combustível que vai ter é
por não ter que ganhar ea prevê e depois
acontecerá a desgraça que aconteceu há
uns dias que devido à espera da cirurgia
se desviará então pode acontecer é ficar
sem combustível tanto vendo um
planejamento antecipado pode exatamente
evitar tudo isso sem ter combustível a
mais na aeronave
o passado como estimavam uma redução da
digamos da pegada de carbono co2 também
então o cavalo como tal nós também temos
a ver o futuro do carioca e uma das
pontes nas peças nós queremos a volta do
futuro é na divulgação mais abrangente
ainda há desafios
eróticas neste momento está muito
relacionado para da vida são de vilões e
neste queremos fazer com que ela vai ser
demais para arrepende da uniso os
potters solução para a crise como vários
varios vários todas as cidades da nato
estarão integradas cada vez mais no
carro aqui juntamos todas as informações
num único portal seja mais fácil para as
pessoas envolvidas ter infecção
assim é e não só entre nós temos estamos
aqui num tempo que é uma é e que é
dedicado aos cai mas existem fóruns
nível nacional é sobre era um autotanque
só sobre a nota que é o carro com pt tem
não só jogar com os players fazer é
ajudar nessa organização mas também
pretendo e passar para uma publicação é
publicação de matéria em perl moda que
os pilotos com material informático com
material aeronáutico e claro de modo que
os frutos lá de novo no vôo e possam é
consultar várias coisas há várias
pessoas que os podem fazê lo e portanto
é ajudarmos o workshop e fazer o
workshop sobre segurança e no fundo é
isso que o cavaco é que temos temos a
pouco os nossos é os nossos é é ajudante
de campo em termos tempo estavam a
forçar para que contassem histórias
famosas entre controladores e pilotos é
eu vou contar se permitem ainda tem
tempo não tem linha não é é uma história
pequena de culpa não é nada interessante
que o contrato é certo que acaba por
terminar em breve mas não é nada de
extraordinário é é aconteceu no no
inverno passado aconteceu o ano passado
e que é um pouco à imagem daquilo que
nós podemos fazer até os pilotos é
quando tem alguma experiência e não
estou aqui vai claro mas de fato
tem alguma experiência a um piloto
escola
vamos contextualizar aqui pra cima o
piloto escola de hoje ao pretendia
proibir lei para a maia é um piloto de
um avião agrícola tanto em termos de
instrumentos de medição não tem quase
news porque olha sempre à vista ajuda em
que brown i sempre à vista não é e
normalmente é para mim é plantar arroz
tanto para vaporizar arroz para
vaporizar o chão do trajeto de 300 os
químicos moda é exatamente um bom tempo
eo que acontece é é acontece que o disco
estava no gol era logo às 7 da manhã
oito da manhã estava no posto que enviou
à usp tinha falado com o cavaleiro de la
luz escola vai para cima de novo é e
quando vai pra cima do velho que eu ver
branco totalmente branco
de tal maneira ver o branco sem
referência em qualquer visual
eu disse então como montanha com está um
pouquinho 9 nada com ninguém
normalmente só numa região que não
comentou com ninguém no hoital é olha
que o tempo é de luxo mas não está à
altura não sabia que eu sabia que essas
aeronaves não tinham qualquer
instrumento qualquer instrumento então
eu não sabia
então olha
suba e meta em transponder que é uma
coisa que nos dá em termos de arrasar a
dar zoom buritizinho nós tivemos que o
hospital e não sabemos é é tentar o
quinto não tivemos que lutar nem aí não
tenho o transponder bom não tenho
transponder é tão sido explodida de vila
real
então olhe vá no 1270 que vai conduzir
tem uma área entre aspas
a musa também não tem bussuan de manhã a
manhã e estudar este baque e sem poder
pensava eu gosto da pessoa o piloto é
fiquei um pouco estava bom sem é radha
saímos lula e não poderia fazer nada
absolutamente nada mas depois lembrei me
pedra e da manhã e se está sob a camada
do ozono é porque tem sol o sol já se
consegue algum lado
então eu disse à senhora olha então que
vai fazer é e eu sabia da participação
em vilar de luz cinco ônibus estava bom
tempo estava bom tempo mas em braga
estava há um bom tempo
então o que o senhor acha então que vai
fazer vai manter o sol às suas costas
o sol atrás de si e vai embora sem o sol
nas suas costas
andou para aí 10 minutos passavam pela
anvisa ou já ouviram linha costa existem
terras na frente e visual com o chão sim
tem visual colchão é que o dia ficou
marcado não só para mim como ficou para
o fim o piloto que é um ato de desespero
não estava porque não tenho qualquer
preferência não servir toda a dívida vai
ser a nossa possui algumas provas passam
por um amigo sua passagem eu poderia
andar perdido até acontecer qualquer
coisa uma das bochechas é tentar ver o
terreno e rodrigo ramal nestas alturas
porque não têm instrumentos não tem nada
que diga onde está
ou então podia como já aconteceu várias
vezes em direção ao oceano e problemas e
minha história que vem
efe
o mercado aqui muito obrigado nunca mais
[Música]